I'm gonna start by saying something you
think you know to be true your brain
creates all facets of your mind
so then why do we treat mental and
physical illnesses so differently if we
think we know that the mind comes from
the brain as a neuroscientist I'm often
told that I'm not allowed to study how
internal states like anxiety or craving
or loneliness are represented by the
brain and so I decided to set out and do
exactly that my research program is
designed to understand the mind by
investigating brain circuits
specifically how does our brain give
rise to emotion it's really hard to
study feelings and emotions because you
can't measure them behavior is still the
best and only window into the emotional
experience of another for both animals
and people
yes self-report is a behavioral output
motivated behaviors fall into two
general classes seeking pleasure and
avoiding pain the ability to approach
things that are good for you and avoid
things that are bad for you is
fundamental to survival and in our
modern day society trouble telling the
difference can be labeled as a mental
illness if I was having car trouble and
I took my car to the mechanic the first
thing they do is look under the hood but
with mental health research you can't
just pop open the hood with the press of
a button so this is why we do
experiments on animals specifically in
my lab mice to understand the brain well
we need to study brains and for the
first time we actually can we can pop
open the hood we can look inside and do
an experiment and see what comes out
technology has opened new windows into
the black box that is our minds the
development of optogenetic tools has
allowed us unprecedented control over
specific neurons in the brain and how
they talk to each other by firing
electrical signals we can genetically
engineer neurons to be light-sensitive
and then use light to control how
neurons fire this can change an animal's
behavior giving us insight into what
that neural circuit can do want to know
how scientists figure this out
scientists developed optogenetic tools
by borrowing knowledge from other basic
science fields algae are single-celled
organisms that have evolved to swim
towards light and when blue light shines
on to the high spot of an algae cell a
channel open sending an electrical
signal that makes little flagella flap
and propels the algae towards sunlight
if we clone this light-sensitive part of
the algae and then add it to neurons
through genetic modification we can make
neurons light-sensitive - except with
neurons when we shine light down an
optical fiber deep into the brain we
change how they send electrical signals
to other neurons in the brain and thus
change the animal's behavior with the
help of my colleagues I pioneered the
use of optogenetic tools to selectively
target neurons that are living in point
a sending messages down wires aimed at
point B leaving neighboring neurons
going other places unaffected this
approach allowed us to test the function
of each wire within the tangled mess
that is our brain a brain region called
the amygdala has long been thought to be
important for emotion and my laboratory
discovered that the amygdala resembles a
fork in the road we're activating one
path can drive positive emotion and
approach and activate another path can
drive negative emotion and avoidance I'm
going to show you a couple of examples a
taste of raw data of how we can use
optogenetics to talk
specific neurons in the brain and get
very specific changes in behavior
anxiety patients have abnormal
communication between two parts of the
amygdala but in people it's hard to know
if this abnormality is cause or effect
of the disease we can use optogenetics
to target the same pathway in a mouse
and see what happens so this is the
elevated plus maze it's a widely used
anxiety test that measures the amount of
time that the mouse spends in the safety
of the closed arms relative to exploring
the open arms mice have evolved to
prefer enclosed spaces like the safety
of their burrows but to find food water
mates they need to go out into the open
where they're more vulnerable to
predatory threats so I'm sitting in the
background here and I'm about to flip
the switch and now when I flip the
switch and turn the light on you can see
the mouse begins to explore the open
arms of the maze more and in contrast to
drug treatments for anxiety
there's no sedation no local motor
impairment just coordinated
natural-looking exploration so not only
is the effect almost immediate but there
are no detectable side-effects now when
I flip the switch off you can see that
the mouse goes back to its normal brain
function and back to its corner when I
was in the lab and I was taking these
data I was all by myself and I was so
excited I was so excited did one of
these quiet screams why was I so excited
I mean yeah theoretically I knew that
the brain controlled the mind but to
flip the switch with my hand and see the
mouse change its behavioral state so
rapidly and so reversibly it was really
the first time that I truly believed it
since that first breakthrough there have
been a number of other discoveries
finding specific neural circuits that
can elicit dramatic changes in animal
behavior here's another example
compulsive overeating we can eat for two
reasons
seeking pleasure
like tasty food or avoiding pain like
being hungry how can we find a treatment
for compulsive overeating without
messing up the hunger driven feeding
that we need to survive the first step
is to understand how the brain gives
rise to feeding behavior this fully fed
Mouse is just exploring a space
completely devoid of any food here we're
using optogenetics to target neurons
living in the hypothalamus sending
messages down wires aimed at the
midbrain when I turn the light on right
here you can see that the mouse
immediately begins licking the floor
this seemingly frenzied behavior is
about to escalate into something I find
really incredible it's kind of trippy
actually ready it's right here he picks
up his hands as if he is eating a piece
of food but there's nothing there he's a
whole anything so this circuit is
sufficient to drive feeding behavior in
the absence of hunger even in the
absence of food I can't know for sure
how this mouse is feeling but I
speculate these neurons drive craving
based on the behaviors we elicit when we
target this pathway turn the light back
off animals back to normal when we
silence this pathway we can suppress and
reduce compulsive overeating without
altering hunger driven feeding what
should you take away from these two
videos that I just showed you that
making a very specific change to neural
circuits in the brain can have specific
changes to behavior that every conscious
experience that we have is governed by
cells in our brain I am the daughter of
a physicist and a biologist who
literally met on the boat coming to
America in pursuit of an education so
naturally since there was no pressure to
be a scientist
as a college student I had to decide
whether I wanted to focus on psychology
the study of the mind or neuroscience
the study of the brain and I chose
neuroscience because I wanted to
understand how the mind is born out of
biological tissue but really I've come
full circle to do both and now my
research program bridges the gap between
the mind in the brain research for my
laboratory suggests that we can begin to
tie specific neural circuits to
emotional states and we have found a
number of circuits that control anxiety
related behavior compulsive overeating
social interaction avoidance and many
other types of motivated behaviors that
may reflect internal emotional states we
used to think of functions of the mind
as being defined by brain regions but my
work shows that within a given brain
region there are many different neurons
doing different things and these
functions are partly defined by the
paths they take here's a metaphor to
help illustrate how these discoveries
change the way that we think about the
brain let's say that the brain is
analogous to the world and that neurons
are analogous to people and we want to
understand how information is
transmitted across the planet sure it's
useful to know where a given person is
located when recording what they're
saying but I would argue that it's
equally important to know who this
person is talking to who is listening
and how the people listening respond to
the information that they receive the
current state of mental health treatment
is essentially a strategy of trial and
error and it is not working the
development of new drug therapies for
mental health disorders has hit a brick
wall with scarcely any real progress
since the 1950s so what does the future
hold in the near future I expect to see
a mental health treatment revolution
where we focus on specific neural
circuits in the brain diagnosis will be
made based on both behavioral symptoms
and measurable brain activity further in
the future by combining our ability to
make acute changes to the brain and get
the cute changes to behavior with our
knowledge of synaptic plasticity to make
more permanent changes we could push the
brain into a state of fixing itself by
reprogramming neural circuits exposure
therapy at the circuit level once we
switch the brain into a state of
self-healing this could potentially have
long-lasting effects with no side
effects I can envision a future where
neural circuit reprogramming represents
a potential cure not just a treatment
okay but what about right now if from
this very moment forward each and every
one of you left this talk and truly
believed that the mind comes entirely
from cells in your brain then we could
immediately get rid of negative
perceptions and stigmas that prevent so
many people from getting the mental
health support that they need mental
health professionals we're always
thinking about what's the next new
treatment but before we can apply new
treatments we need people to feel
comfortable seeking them imagine how
dramatically we could reduce the rates
of suicides and school shootings if
everyone who needed mental health
support actually got it when we truly
understand exactly how the mind comes
from the rain we will improve the lives
of everyone who will have a mental
illness in their lifetime
half the population as well as everyone
else with whom they share the world
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]